[Music]  my game is  cigarettes getting up life  Oh No I'm freaking out ardh I'm not a  racer whatever my best friend all I  gotta do is find a part to fix the game  everything goes back to the way it was  [Music]  my feet don't get my feet go housewives  wanna meet you new wanna get rich  playing video games slaughter race he's  wicked dangerous attention to details  pretty impressive  well well well who are you I think we  should get out of here  Showtime that's right  lovely tears ooh there's so many babies  and cats in the world  I want this to be my life  I don't think I could ever tell her Alf  there's no law saying best friends have  to have the same dreams  [Music]  this is what's called the darknet are  you sure this is safe just whatever you  do do not look at his little brother  little brother what are you doing here  hmm the reason I came to your neck of  the face I mean there's a face in your  neck I mean woods neck of the woods  [Music]